so tonight is the screening screening of
Anderson bench here in LA yes okay
real quickly you mentioned off-camera
about like telling a director the truth
about what you think of their work all
their blood sweat and tears they've
poured into something for several years
what's yours no pressure yeah just be
yourself but what do you think of that
telling someone the truth when you know
having both been on the other end of it
how hard it is to get something off the
ground
well you know when you're watching a
movie nobody who's watching a movie
really knows or cares how hard it is to
get something off the ground they don't
know how you shot it they don't know
that it was raining they don't know that
nobody showed up they didn't know that
the car had no gas they don't know any
of that so so you really can't
as much as filmmakers would like to say
you have no idea how hard this was it's
impossible that we did this and we did
it if the film sucks the film sucks if
the story doesn't if the story doesn't
engage you then it doesn't engage you
and it doesn't matter if you spend a
dollar or doesn't matter doesn't matter
if you're making driving miss daisy'
which didn't cost anything or the Lone
Ranger which costs two hundred million
dollars if you don't have a story
Driving Miss Daisy you could truly have
shot with a cell phone and a Zippo
lighter great story great acting
wonderfully engaging film Lone Ranger
not so much they had to have known they
were they were trying to polish a turd
they really they had to have known that
right I don't know but the whole
question is is that how do you feel
about someone telling you would you
rather someone be brutally honest or
would you rather than from their
perspective absolutely that's not the
question quit tap-dancing I want them to
be brutally honest yeah good you don't
want him to polish a turd no no tell me
if you liked it or if you I would what I
like to do is I like to watch people and
see if they're in gay
in the movie if they if they're laughing
if they're crying if the what do I say
if the weight is on the Bob well if
they're sitting is the weight on their
thighs are on their tailbone that waits
on the tailbone then it's it's like okay
mm-hmm
but if you're like this you're watching
a movie like this if you're leaning in
it means the movie is pulling you into
it regardless of what the story is right
yeah so if a person I guess I'm
tap-dancing if a person is at least
because I am a director I know how
people think right supposed to be
supposed to if people are watching a
movie like this and then when it's over
they say I didn't like that what that
means is they didn't like what it said
to them because it touched a part in
them that they're uncomfortable with
there's no way you can watch a movie
like this and not be engaged in it right
unless you're going I mean you're not
gonna sit for ninety minutes going when
is this thing ever gonna get better
you're not just not going to do that
you're gonna be back here like this you
know be looking at your watch I told the
director once there were there were
there were ten things that you should
never explore in a movie and the movie I
just saw had all eleven of them how'd
that work out I have never worked for
him that's what I didn't think so that's
good though right yeah directness is
always great he produced it I think you
know yeah I didn't I was offended by it
but see I was offended by it mom being
offended and being judged to where if
something's good or not are two
different things I guess that's the
point we're circling back around to
right so when people ask how did you
like the film do you think they really
want to know or are they looking for
praise Wow it depends on who's asking
right
do I hear taps no okay it's that whole
half glass half-full half-empty thing
it's all about perspective and whose ego
you're feeding at the point in time
right and I think that it depends on if
it's a cast member or a director or
produce
or all three from my perspective I want
to hear what the temperature of the film
is and whether they were engaged or not
engaged they keep their attention and
would this be something that they would
recommend to their film their friends so
that's you know from my perspective I
would never ask somebody how they like a
movie I'd say how did that how did that
make you feel what did that make you
feel when you were watching it because
to me because I'm the writer the writer
guy
the director guy it's all about it's all
about feeling it's all about engagement
it's all about if a movie can get under
your skin
what's the high dollar word I know it
I'm gonna write like I said I'm a writer
visceral is it it was it a visceral
experience or were you just kind of was
in our case or in the case of Anderson
bench was it an accident you had to stop
and get out of your car to look at
closer or was it an accident you were
happy to just kind of drive by on the
freeway no I think it's a good analogy
okay yeah so has that take changed for
the two of you now that you're producing
films writing directing now that your
lives have taken a new course with that
I think look do you want to answer
person no you go right ahead I stepped
up first anyway I just started in there
real quick we could I get my window of
opportunity and then shut up so anyway
jump what I think is very interesting on
how John and I originally met our
intentions are very really yeah okay
got it there anyway our intentions of an
approach to filmmaking except for the
physicality part of it because that was
a learning curve but our approach to the
type of cinema and stories that we want
to tell are very much the same and I
think that's where the likeness crossed
over and that's where we immediately
on the same page with one another mm-hmm
is that we both like to evoke emotions
we like to I know I that the from the
films that I've done before in the past
taking a genre and and shaking the genre
and turning it upside down and my
lineage before that was definitely more
independent and trying to acquiesce to
the studio system when I worked under
Robert Evans weighing at Paramount and
Robert Evans when he was at Paramount in
2002 was not like what Robert Evans was
in the 1970s where filmmaking was
definitely more of the vein of or the
approach of what we're doing yeah
there's uh I don't think either one of
our perspectives have really changed
that much I realize because of Alicia's
production savvy I realize you don't
have to spend a bunch of money you can
you can spend you can spend less money
more wisely and as long as you're
telling a story as long as the story is
is on the page and the characters are
fleshed out they're three-dimensional
and and as long as there's something
worth telling then there's no reason in
the world to throw a bunch of money at
it if you don't have to if you have to
and I thought you had to that meant
meant that you had to elicit the the
blessings of several people financial
people studio people a bunch of folks
who who have their own dream and have no
business wallowing around in yours or no
desire this is the what I've learned is
they are no more interested in my dream
than I am in theirs
so if through a relationship
professional relationship like what we
have you can you can get those words
that are on the page fleshed out in
front of a camera and actually make a
movie for pennies on the dollar why in
the world wouldn't you do that so now we
don't have to go to a group of people to
have them bless what we want to do next
we do what we want to do next based on
our schedule based on the weather people
who show up in our lives based on people
who show up
somebody will show up and and we'll
think you know that is the perfect so
and so let's make that movie next yep
well how freeing how great right how
great is that and then when people when
people see them and you know this is we
are we are sitting on perhaps the eve of
our destruction who have any idea what
we're gonna have people tonight C
Anderson bench that have no idea what it
is they're gonna see a a very I think
different kind of love story and it is
representative of what we both like to
do to the norm it's a young love story
okay well that's like you said let's
let's let's push it let's turn it inside
out let's let's let's rip it in half
let's let's reach it let's reach down
the love story's throat and and invert
it violently which is more my take oddly
enough that's where my mind goes when we
do something about murder murder mystery
it's the same thing it's like what and
that's so refreshing to work with
someone who is as is as not saying
forward thinking because who knows what
that is but we are like-minded as far as
storytelling goes and we're not hinging
on whether or not we get a thumbs up or
thumbs down we're still gonna make
movies that's not that right because we
like it it's just fine we enjoy it I did
country music for a long time and and
you are destined to fail as soon as you
are trying to make as soon as they a
group of talented creative people are
trying to make something that some other
group are going to like what you need to
make is a group of talented excited
people about whatever it is you're
making could be dental implants whatever
it is you're making you have to be
right about it you have to think you
know this is I this is fantastic this is
what I like you cannot I don't believe
you can honestly make something for a
demographic that is not you you can't
make movies or towels or soap that you
would not use absolutely do I agree with
that in terms of the story and ripping
it wide open in a relationship it also
signifies and I'm speaking of your film
Anderson bench someone who's awoken to
to maybe how their life was going and
then they see it in a new way for the
two of you having both been in LA at one
time how freeing is it to be now in
another part of the country where do you
feel more creative in some sense because
there's less of the LA hustle and bustle
are you able to then formulate stories
or ideas and a different pace or
different rate I think you should answer
first time because mine's different than
that sure a lot of the ones a lot of the
movies were making I think I still I
still lived in Los Angeles when I wrote
Anderson bench but I didn't want to I
was with somebody who wanted to get out
wanted to escape escape from LA because
I felt put upon and I felt judged and
condemned and trapped and all those
things at Anderson bench feels so once I
got out of here instead and moved to
Louisiana there is a there is a it's a
lot freer there and it's interesting in
that there's a lot of a lot of politics
going on everywhere at the gas station
at the at the county seat I mean there's
a lot of stuff going on in Louisiana
that's probably going on here but we're
unaware of it as we're so far away from
Sacramento but I find it to be a very
very feeding place creatively
but I don't feel as nearly as they say
you can't really sing the blues and so
you've had them I'm very happy guy now
when I wrote these when I wrote Anderson
bench I was not a very happy guy I was
like writing Anderson bench and like
that and now it just makes me laugh
i watch anderson bench and it's it's
freeing it's freeing for me but I do
prefer I prefer the the atmosphere
sitting on the back porch and in
Louisiana with the cypress trees and the
cypress knees and the frogs I find that
to be much more personally fulfilling
personally feeding and I write different
kind of things and when were there yeah
different definitely changed yeah which
is great it's a new perspective for me
filmmaking has come full circle there so
originally I came from Louisiana worked
my way into LA and through the system of
independence and always have done
independence that walked our you know
beat to a different drum and then
finally worked my way into the studio
system and then really felt like there
was door slammed constantly in my face
but Louisiana for me definitely was full
full circle starting off initially in
the film industry there
and telling stories there so it's a
different perspective yeah and you know
there's nothing that I hope it doesn't
sound like we're pooh-poohing the studio
sister I understand why the studio
system is what it is I mean and it's
there's nothing wrong with it it's a
it's a corporate creative mentality it's
more business than show that's why they
make so much money I mean I understand
that and I don't fault it at all it's
just never been I am NOT a corporate
personality she is not a corporate
personality we have never been that in
times where we've had to have been
broken and shoehorned into a corporate
kind of a box
we have tolerated it
at best but it's not our personalities
we are destined to make very loud
mistakes I am anyway yeah I'm sorry
which the only people who succeed I
think in life and anything are those who
are willing and apt to make very loud
mistakes so there I hear that okay cool
then you have you probably were thinking
anything well no so you have to look
like this you also have to look at
things too with how we do things you
know like Anderson bent is a perfect
example when how so how you know you
have your intention when you're writing
something and then there's an
interpretation side and then it's you
know how does this fit now or how you
know and then it's kind of like us
talking and or speaking in the abstract
with whatever we're approaching and
what's gonna work what I think is some
of the interesting things about us too
and it's also not taking it's great to
have one your depth of experience and my
set of experience and then collaboration
on what we're doing with things shown I
mean like how we cast Anderson bench was
on a certain path and then it's when we
started casting it we shifted into a
different direction that was her fault
was great um but that's what I think
that's what the tag team between us
don't I mean it's both of our skill sets
we only have to ask us right and here's
the thing we may be wrong right
the-the-the we may be wrong and people
may look at these movies and go no no
thank you
but the cool thing is it's it's our
investment and I don't have anyone we
don't have anyone to make it up to we
don't have anyone to apologize to we
aren't so desperate to make the money
back because she's so smart at how at
how the money is spent we're not so
desperate to make the money back that
we're willing to compromise whatever we
feel is the right way to tell a story
the right way to cast a film the right
location
shoot a film in we don't have that
element which is oh my god it's so
freeing but we may be wrong but if we're
right and if we're wrong it doesn't
matter what I'm tomorrow we'll do
another one what were some of the things
that you you felt the money should be
spent on and then conversely not spent
on like what were some of the things
that you were surprised that maybe of
how tweaking in the budget here and
there actually benefited you and I am I
am surprised and I'm honored because I
have to believe that it has to do with
with the screenplays that there are
people of the caliber who are in these
films that are willing to work for so
little for a chance that the movie will
work and then everyone gets something on
the back end I'm one of those people
who's been cheated cheated bad word I've
been one of those people who have been
the victim of creative bookkeeping as
far as the back end of films are
concerned for decades we are not going
to be that person I we talk about all
the time I can't wait to call a meeting
at the at the studio and have dinner
Alicia will make some amazing dinner and
we'll sit there and we'll we'll talk
about something and then hand people
checks and they have no idea that that's
what they're coming here for I want to
hand them big checks because they bet on
this horse and they won and I live for
that day
not for mmm how can we how can we cheat
people out of it so we've got folks so
I'll work for it's it's AG ultra-low
budget I mean we work for nothing
yeah we worked for a hundred bucks but
if the words are good I'll work for a
hundred bucks never would have before
but I see the kind of people who are
coming to work for us for a hundred
dollars a day and we have a great
amazing amazing across the board yeah
yeah it's it's it's wonderful and
hopefully I mean that's one of the
reasons why I want I want them to work
obviously I want people to go oh my gosh
Anderson benches is Harold and Maude for
a new age you know I want that
and if they do then then everyone will
will reap the benefits of it but if they
don't they'll still show up and do
another one and maybe that's the one and
if that's not the one then they'll show
up for the one after that and maybe
that's the one they're willing to to
roll the creative dice with us time
after time after time I'm not sure I
think what's really cool too is that
we've now developed a family of
filmmakers and they all which I think
it's great with when your regard to the
actors is that they all play distinctly
different characters in each film you
need to film it is amazing
and it's like wait a minute is that the
same guy from and it's just they'll know
an accents dress and it's great so
they're getting fulfilled also you know
not only are they you know enjoying the
different types of projects we're doing
but they're bringing a lot to the table
and getting to show their diversity as
an actor too which is great yeah they
know the actor actors had come in they
know we've got a great guy Duke Davis
Roberts I watched him grow up he's a
friend of my son and we were getting
ready to do he's the guy that runs the
drive-through liquor store in Anderson
bench and he said well what do you want
what do you want I said I said I want
what no one would expect from you and he
said what is that and I said I have no
idea work it out did you mean I can I
can like do anything I said do whatever
it is no one in their right mind would
let you do and he did that's what I want
and that's exactly what he did and he'd
say he went he said can I have like we
do like black out some of my teeth and
do this little greasy hair thing and she
said yeah let's do it and did it and
then just said what would Chasen same
thing with Jason and it oh well they
wore that mullet did not one no there's
a common thread that would Chasen would
kill him in every movie we do that's not
good to kill my son
in every movie oh well did we kill him
in the play too did he die in a
Shakespeare cadiz I am an imaginary one
thank you doing
anyway tough tough to be the be the son
I understand the two of you may or may
not soon be meeting with theaters and
different distributors do you know we
may oh you may okay so it is hot okay
we're all right okay not with
distributors not oh why are you ready to
go that yeah well there's a we are
meeting there be distributors this won't
be out before tonight so there are
distributors there are people who are
coming to see Anderson bench tonight but
we're talking about meeting with with
theatres I've done this one time before
can we also interject real quick
certainly we can what would we like to
say well we like to say the Royal we
right you have to kind of go back to how
the vaudeville days were turning in and
then that kind of gives people a little
bit more insight which is taking into
the road shows doing the Mike Todd
things was a call to trucking a truck
and pony truck and pony show what's the
expression it was a dog and pony dog and
pony show dog and pony
there was a truck a bus and truck was
right when when you do when there was
also theater it's a bus and truck or you
pedal pedaled so they had theater owners
that would pedal they would bicycle and
that would start pedal there print right
the next theater and they they owned
groups of theatres and so it's um there
are still theater owners there are
theater owners like there are still
there are still Susannah owners there
are theater owners like that in the
south or the southern region I don't
know many in the North but anyway that's
what more than that only theaters and so
back then you would bicycle one you
would start off at one theater and that
reel was bicycle to the next theater so
you could start the movie in that
theater so they would own one print his
kind of thing you know I actually did
that right you bicycle well I took I was
in my Dodge truck but yeah right but
that's gonna do it that's where that
comes from is from the original single
screen movie theater owners and it was
called bicycling
right peddling you'd peddle from one
place to the other anyway go ahead so
that's a no that's that's where things
tense right this educational moment
brought to my bicycle there's a I I
believe that there's a way around
everything there's a way around that the
the entire industry has changed it's
it's it's easier to make movies now the
only thing it's not easier to do now is
is to get distribution because the same
people are in control of distribution
and god bless him there's nothing wrong
with with that but it's it's corporate
people or not necessarily creative
people non creative people at the very
last stage of a creative process that
makes no sense that by the time you get
to right just before you're gonna bring
the birthday cake out with the candles
on it you've got somebody with a fire
extinguisher right like you can't have
that out here well wait a minute why
it's a birthday cake with candle no no
you can't do that there are children out
there yes it's a child's birthday don't
you understand
it's a little bit of a tangent but so
what we're trying to do 34 years ago I
and a group of people recognized a flaw
in fundraising and it was very much the
same thing people would raise money and
by the time the money was just about
ready to go where it needed to go
someone else got a hold of it and it
didn't go to the right place or someone
took something off the top and it didn't
it just it was a flawed system so four
people started something called the
Children's Miracle Network and in less
than fifteen years we became the single
largest children's charity in the world
and we still are because we didn't know
any better than to have somebody with a
fire extinguisher blowing the candles
out before Johnny got to make a wish
okay
so what we believe now is that there are
tremendously expensive theater chains
out there that are owned by people who
are in the movie business they just
spent they're on the hook for 4050
million dollars for a Cineplex because
they want to be in the movie business
because they love the Old Yeller and
they love the Godfather and they loved
Harold and Maude and they loved Herbie
the lovebug and loved and loved and
loved and loved and loved but now
because they have a mortgage and because
they they have a loan and because they
they are now being forced to be more in
the business model than the show model
and I believe that to be true do I have
anything to back that up no but for me
it seems like common sense well this
makes sense so I think there's a way to
make a deal to distribute films directly
to cinema owners rather than have to go
this way which for me seems like the
long way around the barn just go right
to the people who are selling popcorn
and offer them content offer them a way
to put butts in seats but offer them a
way to be back in the show part of show
business so that's what that's what
we're involved in right now and it may
we may be we may be barking howling at
the moon I have no idea it's worth a try
right we have to and it's that's the fun
part of it and I think that we both are
like-minded in the sense that we have to
make it back to it being an event and
that's why I bring up vaudeville it was
always the juggler before the show or
this or that before the show and that's
what there's a lot of connecting parts
that we're talking about but it's
connecting with those theater owners who
have been in business since the 1920s
30s and 40s they're family these are the
grandchildren of people who started who
built the first theater right and it's
really taking them the content and then
creating this
vent and I don't want to say at all
because there's certain connecting
elements that we're doing but there's a
lot there's a whole lot to it
it is a roadshow type yeah
venue let's suppose you're interviewing
a theater owner you've got your movie
you've got it
gut questions you don't want to give
away this precious baby to just anyone
what questions are you asking I would
ask a theater owner if they're happy if
they are doing what they thought they
would be doing really if you're happy
yeah well right there are people who I
think personally I think used-car
salesmen who own the lot are happier
than the number one salesman at whoever
and whoever Chevrolet or whoever and
whoever Chrysler Dodge or dodge or who
yeah because they're the ones that they
go out and they make deals on inventory
they bring the inventory in and they
know the vehicles they know which ones
run they know which ones don't they know
the high mileage cars the low mileage
cars and know where the knocks are they
know all that and they are unstirred so
they're educated on their product and
they are proud on some level of their
product and they they rely on a
relationship with their customer base so
they're not gonna lie to somebody about
some you know the third and yellow it's
yellow that's not a lemon it's just
yellow when they know it doesn't really
work they know it's not gonna get these
folks home so to me those are people
because you're gonna come back to them
and say hey Bobby what's up with this
suburban you said it would run it
doesn't didn't get me home they don't
want that they want you to come by and
say hey I was at the donut shop and I
brought you a cup of coffee in my new
suburban and that great thanks Bobby
I have to think that people maybe I'm
naive but I have to think that on some
level the most basic level of humankind
that that's how they want to feel they
want to be proud about what they do
they don't want to do what they're told
they don't want to they don't want to
and so that I would think would boil
down to people who own 16 or 32 Plex
down the street they've got a lot of
money invested
and it's not to say that they're gonna
shift turn I mean it's no they're not
like kick everybody out right they're
still gonna make their money with the
big boys but the creative part of them I
think is lacking and I think that's what
hopefully they're gonna see or entreat
them about what our slate of films that
we're bringing them and it's not just
our slate it's other filmmakers and
hopefully creating more of a collective
group of filmmakers not be an avenue for
independent filmmakers to actually be
able to get on a big screen right
Alabama in North Carolina wherever
wherever it is instead of being told
when they can show stuff and then being
limited now it's a way to almost
piggyback little movies on yes so are
you happy yeah when I did when I when I
released Collier and company worked with
the theater chain out of out of Georgia
and I moved the prints from theater to
theater to theater and wherever I showed
up I did radio interviews and television
interviews and we outsold whatever movie
whatever big studio movie was in the
theater for that evening only for that
evening but that was good
we had people watching the movie people
enjoying it people buying popcorn
theater owner was happy I as a creative
person was being fed and an audience was
enjoying themselves and they still come
to me and say hey I saw a Collier and
company in Savannah Georgia and it was
great when are you gonna make another
one that makes me feel great so much
more so than hey I saw you in some movie
I don't even know where I I did it
because you know my little cardboard
sign and I'm an actor it says will will
act for food right I much prefer the
other and I have to believe like I said
I have to believe basic human nature you
don't get in the automobile business if
you hate cars you don't get in the movie
theater business if you don't like to
see people with the weight on the on the
front of their seats watching something
that excites them and taking them away
you have to be that kind of person
inside I I believe that you did
it has to be true and if it's not then
we're wrong and we'll build a drive-in
like well build a drive-in we'll do it
over we'll do it ourselves and we'll
have the weight on it on the Front's of
our butts okay so are you happy so that
so suppose they're they're just grinning
from ear to ear and they're not the
place for us okay I mean they but they
seem happy right but if they say that
they're if they're if they're if there's
no void to be filled and obviously
there's no room but I do think that
there's yeah we're looking it's it's all
over Anderson bench are you are you
content Anderson what content is any
exists of course I'm not right they're
having a good day but of course I'm not
do you ever think you could be said why
bother
but if I could have one content day I
could die a happy man and I think sadly
that's where a lot of people live they
don't think they deserve to be happy
they don't deserve to be content it's
not possible to wake up in the morning
and do what you love to do we think
quite different it's not possible not to
wake up in the morning it's not possible
to wake up in the morning and not do
what you love to do the same thing you
were thinking about when you went to
sleep it's the same thing you start
doing when you wake up in the morning
and that's how that's how we're living
and it's a choice it's not it we're not
lucky we're not fortunate we haven't
been hit with the with the lucky stick
we just refuse to believe otherwise keep
working and that's what Anderson bench
is about in in a very real way now will
people will people see that when they
see the movie all the way through
unfasten ated to find out Anderson bench
was born of the question if you knew
beyond a shadow of a doubt that you had
just lived the best day of your life not
just the best day you've ever had but
the best day you will ever have
how would you end it
yeah and he talks about just warning
when he is questioned just wanting to
make it through without screwing things
up yeah yeah right yeah that's a
goal Anderson sorry yeah it's all Anders
yeah you know people deserve better than
that she says that you deserve to be
happy
you should be happy and it kind of puffs
a little wind in his sails there are two
kinds of people in the world I think
there are people who well they're three
people people who who do nothing people
who take knives to every sale that they
see and and cut a hole in the middle so
it can be less effective and people who
blow wind in your sails to help you get
down the road so which one are you
theater owner car salesman which one of
those people are you that's what I want
to know and those are the those those
are the concepts that that are around
the movies we make so let's suppose
ideal wise personality wise you mesh
with this theater owner what are some
other questions you're asking because
you can have a great relationship with
someone like them but maybe the business
side of it isn't for you so what are
some questions do you think you'd ask as
well what do you need what can we do for
you right absolutely I mean it's also
you know our approach to how we're going
to feed and promote and relationships
that were calling upon and it's a lot of
different things what are you what are
you looking for and it's what do you
need is not something that people are
used to being asked everybody goes to to
these sorts of well nobody's really
having these sorts of meetings but
basically a meeting is about me trying
to get something from you and I think
that's wrong so again we're inverting
that model too this meeting is about
what can we give to you what do you need
and how can we help you get it and also
work cooperatively turn them in and I
think that's where the
the shift is and it's the same way with
our approach to filmmaking too is that
most people are you know when we start
talking about screenplays here to agents
and stuff like that they were like you
know the first thing is financing and
then how can they help get financing
it's like no we already have our
financing everything we do is very
atypical yeah and including how we're
marketing and how we're gonna deal with
the theater owners without giving too
much away it's a very atypical
approach when we started Children's
Miracle Network we were something that
hospitals needed and didn't even realize
they needed it and we're in the service
business that's it we raise money for
Children's Hospital don't tell them how
to use it don't even suggest how they
use it totally non discretionary funding
unheard of now it's been unheard of for
34 years and we've raised over five
billion dollars with not a single string
or thread attached to any single dollar
that we've raised same thing with this
model this model is your your grant I
heard a wonderful story the other day
about this guy's grandpa who started
this this theater chain who was a mayor
and he dressed up like Boss Hogg from
Dukes and he was heavy and everybody
loved him and he was that he was a
showman and this is a guy who started a
very successful theater chain and it's
become it went from showman grandpa to
business business business business
still wonderful showman family but
there's there there's a lot of business
involved and
I they love
don't I guarantee you no one has ever
sat in the office in their office and
said what can we do for you and that
boils down to when you were a kid what
watch what kind of movies you could cut
one screen off of all the screens that
you have and dedicate it to something
that would make you smile what would
that be they'll tell us and we either
have it or we'll find it or we'll make
it let's suppose you're having lunch
with two producing partners and they say
we found this great Cineplex that we
want to show our film at we really mesh
with a theater owner and you say great
make sure ABC and D are done what would
those things be money-wise contract wise
what would you advise just to make sure
relationships great otherwise that's you
that's all you really it's more about
promotion at that point don't I mean
because it's a relationship on that and
it's really the time that you're
targeting of the space and then how are
you gonna market your project and that's
the hard part of for waling and that's
why most people fail at it so I can
throw one thing in there I would tell
them to make sure that they're willing
to have this this venture with this
theater chain for this evening that
they're showing their movie or however
long it is they have to be willing and
able for that to lose money they have to
they have to spend more than they expect
to make in order to make it successful
so that that theater chain or some other
theater chain will go hey we went in on
that right it's also just not about one
night never about one night it's about
it's a it truly is The Tortoise and the
hare
it is this is a long race and you have
to be willing to be in it for a long
long time it's possible to hit the ball
out of the park the first night it's not
likely but it's possible
then you have to go back and look at all
the the reason why they're there are
one-hit wonder groups in music way back
when is their first song was a huge hit
they had nothing to back it up with it
would have been better for their first
song to have been top 20 their second
tonk song to have been top ten their
third song have been top five and the
fourth one to be number one so you have
to factor that you have to factor in
longevity and it's hard for it's
especially hard for young people to
think about longevity people ask me all
the time did you think Dukes of Hazzard
was gonna last this long and I said
anything I was gonna last this long yeah
I didn't I didn't know that we were all
supposed to die in 2000 remember I know
I'm supposed to be terrible
y2k marketing so yeah you have to be
willing to lose money can't be about the
money if it's not about the money you'll
make money if it's about the money he
won't I agree
percent so what if a theater says we
don't do 5050 splits and you're going to
have to put up a screening fee of X
amount of dollars for the week or the
night there's that's all stuff that's in
negotiation and that's why you pick and
choose your x and that's all part of a
strategy on how you approach that
theater owner and that's all part of
that questionnaire what's working and
what's not working and where are their
weak spots okay because we've known
people that they've wanted to screen in
other cities that were very expensive
and it was it was worth it to them to
lose money they wanted to put up whether
they had to do it on their credit card
or not a huge chunk because they wanted
that coverage in that city and the major
paper they wanted all the things that
went along with that so you feel that
maybe sometimes it is worth the risk as
long as you're not being taken advantage
of I mean there are there are folks who
will take advantage of the young
filmmaker or the young car salesman the
young whatever and just you have to be
smart you can't just say okay well I'm
gonna throw out a bunch of money you
have to be smart and negotiate with them
so a lot of its relationship to I mean
as anything in this industry you know
everything is relationship based the
relationships that you have and the
relationships that I have that theater
owners that we're going to speak with
are some are your side of the coin and
some from my side of the coin right I
mean it's not like we're just calling up
cold calling it's relationships that's
why you've been in the business as long
as you have and I have too but again
we're not going it's you're wearing it
we're in a very unique position I I
recognize that but we're taking
advantage of it if we go in and say hey
what can we do for you it's different
than somebody that nobody has any idea
who they are coming in and say what can
what can we do for you true but there's
nothing wrong with it's not unfair to
take advantage of your advantage it's
stupid not to so that's what that's what
we're going to do but we have to deliver
if someone nobody knows goes in and says
hey I want to try this I'd love to help
you out yet have you known as the
independent filmmaker friend and then
they they better deliver it doesn't mean
they have to make money they just better
do what they say they're gonna do and
they better be vigilant in showing up
and making sure that that they've
they've got the advertising they said
they'd get they've done everything they
can to make sure people come to the
movie people aren't aren't mean they'll
they'll say well kid you know you really
worked hard at that better luck next
time and when when you're ready to do it
next time call me they'll do that but if
you come in and just talk in a big game
and then don't follow it up don't even
try forget it you're not gonna work for
me or you or anybody in this in this
room or in the other room so John for
your career how much acting work have
you booked on your own and how much have
you relied on agent hahaha and how do
you feel about both roles and about one
how do you feel about both roles and
which wish which roles in which others
are more fulfilling
once you booked on your own
or once once we started the studio and
started doing doing what we want to do
in Louisiana I no longer saw a need for
representation there's a line in a movie
we just finished my guy says that's a
distraction distraction happens you know
that's you're not doing what you don't
want to do because of life because life
got in the way you got distracted
distracted happens I think that the
those other kinds of jobs are
distractions I really do I think I do
believe without getting all spiritual
and supernatural on you I I do believe
that there are forces that will try to
get a focused individual or a team of
individuals off their game because a
team of individuals who are focused
can't help but do good things for those
they come in contact with and I do
believe there's stuff out there that
wants to squelch that at every possible
opportunity so those things I believe
are distractions I thank God every day
for the haves and have-nots working with
with Tyler Perry on The Oprah Winfrey
Network is an amazing an amazing actor
job and it's an amazing school for me to
learn and I was not I told both of them
I said I was not ready to learn anything
after 50 I didn't think there was
anything else I needed to know because I
was still working on the lessons I had
and that came through an agent that that
job came through an agent the rest of
the work since then has come through
relationships not getting rich by that
stuff at all but doing very interesting
different kinds of things like Alicia
was talking about if you come to the
studio and do a movie you're going to be
doing a character no one else will
we want you to do or allow you to do or
consider you to do so I get off on that
as an actor but as far as as far as
representation I don't think John
Schneider doesn't have time for it right
now John Schneider studios and the
movies that we're doing needs
representation the movies they need
representation I don't and life gets
better after 50 life gets so much better
after it's all a game until you turn 50
and then it's really fun why because
you're doing what you know you can do
you're no longer worried about I mean
everybody's younger than you so you're
no longer thinking oh my goodness what
are the adults gonna think screw them
were the adults now I'm not there yet
that's true that's true
mentally I'm 80 do you think most of us
idolize actors and respect them are they
like royalty in the u.s. I think so um
I think you get more of that from more
of the old school I think that you get
less of that now and I think that
they're I think you're seeing now a
dynamic shift and I think we're gonna
see more of a dynamic shift in
television I actually think that we're
going to hopefully go back to the old
you know having movie stars I really do
Clark Gable yeah we yeah and less
vulgarity and stuff even though we yeah
there's one way on telling a story but
then there's the other way of you know
doing vulgar things outside of your
storytelling world Oh true you know I
mean that's what I'm getting at I mean I
think that I understand that I think
that there's gonna I think that there's
a dynamic shift happening and I see that
in my daughter's generation so in the 20
year olds I'm starting to see more of
that of a change I used to be something
called standards and practices and we've
lost anymore and I think that I
Department
that it's slowly coming back to I think
that we're just seeing the break of that
now that wave is just starting
yeah sorry no I think that's good so
chivalry is was sleeping
perhaps chivalry was not dead mm-hmm who
was sleeping it's when Clark Gable was
Clark Gable and Jimmy Stewart was Jimmy
Stewart and John Wayne was John Wayne it
was hard to get your your face in a box
or on a screen impossible I mean other
than slides at home or maybe super 8 or
16-millimeter films that Uncle Charlie
took at the birthday party you couldn't
get there it was it was technologically
impossible for you to get there you know
now some hamster does a backflip out of
his bowl which we watched the other day
I'm on YouTube sitting there just like
oh look at the hamster doing a backflip
out of the bowl now all you have to be
as a hamster that does a backflip out of
a bowl so I think that has eroded the
whole notion of celebrity I think the
reality TV has eroded the notion of
celebrity I think that no one will ever
have any idea if Paris Hilton has any
talent and for a long time nobody cared
she may she may be amazing at something
she may be Lady gaga in front of a piano
I have no idea and no one will know
because she became famous for she became
a celebrity for being a celebrity
somehow already good that chef well I
don't I hope it changes but I maybe
what'll happen is that because you can
get a camera like this and because you
can edit it on your laptop like that one
over there and make something worthy of
being viewed by a populace
maybe what will happen is what happened
in I see a lot of parallels with the
music industry that the music industry
became after the labels went away when
GarageBand happened to your computer and
Napster happened to publishing and
mechanical royalties when that basically
destroyed a business overnight what
emerged from that was the
singer-songwriter which had been around
Kris Kristofferson was around Hanks
senior was around mean the the people
were around before but that that kind of
came up because those are people who
can't not do it
right so now what we have are people
hopefully like us who are saying what
wait a minute we we have to make a movie
we have got to it's it's July we haven't
made a movie yet we got we have to make
this movie which one I don't know who's
available let's make a movie so
hopefully what will come out of this
whole cacophony of celebrity hamsters
doing backflips out of bowls will be the
real storytellers that have partnered
with the real technicians that can get
those stories in front of a population
otherwise I think it's going to be more
hamsters and bowls and more talent free
people making $100,000 to show it up at
a nightclub that's going to go away in
six months anyway I mean it's a very
strange time yeah but I think that's
where the opportunity is do you know I
think so yeah for the real the real the
real artists I really want to go correct
and take the risk you have to be the
risk-taker too right and that cannot be
about making the money that's right you
have to take the risk
most most artists were dead long before
anybody knew they were alive Rembrandt
Knight Picasso absolutely they were they
were moderately successful until all of
a sudden you can get those anymore
right well that's more of it isn't it no
we had this conversation the other day
that's just me morbid maybe I should
kill you first
death by your own hand no it has to be
by my own hands I'll let you know shoot
you thank you yeah using Anderson bench
as a case study what were the first
steps in producing a film the first
steps well when we have to the director
and I have to be on the same page on
what type of movie we're gonna to make
then what's the approach in the budget
how many days we're going to shoot it in
and then the tone of it and then if all
of those stars align then we set out to
pragmatically put the project together
cast it and then come up with a schedule
and then shoot and fly people in and out
I like to start with the big pieces
first
so in Anderson bench the the one
location we shot out most was Anderson's
house so we started there it's always
easier to start outside because you if
it's not raining you film outside if it
is raining you go inside can i interject
real quick sure our first thing wasn't
we shot you in the house sorry what's
our philosophy well you have to start
before you can stop yep it's hard to
stop something that's in motion it's
hard to start something but once you
have it's hard to stop it once it's in
motion so the first thing we shot and
she shot it
she was the camera operator and it was
me talking on the phone with my nose
running and the glasses and a cigar and
all that talking to Anderson bench
because I knew we were gonna start
shooting the next day we're gonna do the
movie the next day but we had to start
and we had to show the cast and crew
that snot dripping awful disgusting
scenes so that they won't understand the
tone of Anderson bench because they
didn't know whether to laugh or vomit
when they saw those dailies
it's okay both
it is and cry what was I doing for the
days before that before we did that with
will out in the driveway
what was I building but then Emma right
the Machine couldn't film a movie
without Emma I mean we do everything so
we do art department we build we
character we do wardrobe everything is
talked about we shot at the back of that
machine because the the roller thing
where that people go down in it whoops
spoiler Widow that's all right with the
people it did sit promise film right the
promise of the premise wasn't in yet so
yeah we shot at the back well it came in
later that afternoon so we installed it
and then got to shoot around the front
of it but I mean we just we just go for
it yep but you can't it's a good lesson
in life you cannot it's hard to stop
something once you've started so
sometimes you have to just start and you
still need to be strategically aligned
yes that's a critical thing having those
conversations director producer and
making sure that we're a writer and that
we're all making the same movie mm-hmm
true and it's great because I trust him
a hundred percent and I trust her 100%
yeah she says no you can't do it that
way okay how can we do it and vice versa
and if he says we're gonna finish on
time today
don't worry about it we're gonna finish
on time and a probably extra time yeah
which is great so fantasy and reality
merging one raining one in one shooting
out ideas one thing we can but this has
to happen I don't think that it's
raining each other end I really think
that both are abstract thinkers and we
both articulate life experience as well
and I think that it's not about pulling
one back I think that it's just saying
this is what the boundaries are and you
got to maneuver through them and I feel
the same way during I mean I have
boundaries that I have to maneuver to
help him achieve his goals you know so
that it's a it's a it's a tit-for-tat I
was definitely not a reining in it's
like
it's just each other guiding well I'll
have some notion about doing something
and you'll say oh there's a lot more
time than that do it do it doing how you
really want to do it cuz I'll say well I
don't think we're I think we're gonna
run out of time said you're not gonna
run at a time you're smarter than that
do it the way you want okay so I will
and it's great fun it has a great show a
lot of experience with that you know and
I think that working with filmmakers
directors and producers your side of the
coin and my son of the coin have allowed
us to be able to relax turning me in
right actors relax people that actors in
these movies do things they have it's
not about fun I mean it fun sounds like
oh it's just fun and silly and fun no
it's fun because it's freeing right it's
fun like like winning excuse me like
winning a baseball game is fun I don't
care what they say losing a baseball
game not so much fun it's it's it's the
it's the thrill of doings of having your
your not having your wings clipped but
having someone blow air up underneath
your wings like the song and make you
better than you are she makes me better
than I am I hope that I helped make
actors and set people everybody better
than they are we are we are we are
better together than we are apart
what's the synergy yeah we all have
synergy having your own studio where you
go for investment what do you mean well
you have your own studio at work we put
money into our studio everything we make
everything we make we put into the
studio okay
so just like paramount does so the same
way parent paramount does puts money
into we do the same thing except it's
just he and I and ours is not as fancy
editing Bay's everything there for color
correction things like we have
everything shooting we do sound we have
stages mm-hmm sets a bamboo forest
bamboos what old barn
what's fascinating is we both made
before we met
we both
movies while we met on on hate crime but
we both were experimenting or believing
in the other model get people to invest
in the movie have the movie be
successful pay them back so we both have
one we owe money on oh people money on
people that we know not people that are
you know these are the people that are
gonna come back in the suburban that
doesn't work and get in our face we both
have that in our right behind us and it
bothers me knowing that that I owe
somebody money that somebody believed in
me and I have been able to pay them back
yet I don't want to feel that way
anymore so we won't we're not gonna do
that anymore
we don't know we haven't and we won't we
don't have the money to make the movie
we'll either figure out a way to make
the movie for less or you won't make the
movie tender one we'll make the movie
just with the iPhone then absolutely
well we've got the same cameras we're
not going to lose the cameras right we
have all the toys now right the cameras
are paid for right so we can still make
the movie okay all right excellent
being properly insured what are some
things you could advise other filmmakers
to insure their equipment everything is
critical to have insurance I mean
obviously to do a movie we have to have
insurance yeah there's not everyone's so
sophisticated nowadays so I'm not gonna
let you step foot on their property
without having proper insurance so and
that's and there's great I have great
old relationships with that I mean I'm
one of the gentlemen Kent Hamilton I've
known him for since I was 18 years old
and the business and he's still out
there insurance companies and every
filmmaker should have insurance and you
can pull your insurance together I mean
that's you know independent filmmakers
really should pull their relationships
and pull their resources you know that's
what we're doing we're pooling our stuff
together how can they pull insurance
together that's good I didn't know that
you can invite a policy to aware the
policy I'm giving away all my secrets
okay but how we're doing it is that
there are insurance
since his name and my name and
collectively we use it and then we use
it over identified projects and that's
how I've done things before in the past
so it makes it more affordable to I feel
my girl John why are you making such a
strong move to produce write and direct
at this stage of your career you've done
many things and it seems like hmm now
you're taking this well
first of all she produces I don't
produce okay yeah I don't know from I
don't know from producing at all because
if two of us are the same one of us is
unnecessary I thought I was gonna be
doing this right after Dukes I wrote and
directed the last episode of Dukes and
thought that naturally what I'd be doing
from that point on was telling stories
and I had written a couple of
screenplays and they really weren't very
good so I'm glad that it didn't happen
wasn't ready for it but I've always been
trying before Dukes when I was eight
millimeter film fifty feet at a time
with no sound that you'd have to have
developed at Kaldor in Mount Kisco New
York that's what I was doing cutting
pieces of film together with tape on a
shag carpet
so I being a filmmaker or a storyteller
has always been what what I felt if you
said what John what do you do I said
well I tell stories
well you're singing country music yeah
but I'm telling stories well you're
doing this and doing that well yeah but
I'm telling stories the difference is
now they're they're my stories
they're they're my experiences that have
come out and and like rust on a bumper
they have got to come out they've got to
see the light of day you can't just keep
painting them over or one of these days
the bumpers gonna fall off so have to
have to tell them but it's through this
relationship that I realize I actually
could there's a lot to it there's a
whole lot to it's why I'm
to say I'm not a producer producers are
the ones that actually make they set the
stage so that the magic can happen and
in there by doing create their own kind
of magic but without them their stories
you just tell over and over they change
every time you tell them because you get
bored and then they kind of go away and
I'm glad they're not going away anymore
right was i messing with my glasses look
yeah where I took away from me sorry